[Music]
three decades of regret eddie murphy
turned down playing a different eddie
and one of disney's greatest cult
classics why he thought the movie was
just too weird
eddie murphy is as iconic as his movies
the actor and comedian is legendary
thanks to films like coming to america
beverly hills cop and shrek but even
though murphy has played some of the
most recognizable roles in hollywood
he's also had the bad luck of playing
some of the worst the actor has been
nominated for nine razzie awards and
managed to take home three thanks in
part to the likes of norbit and the
adventures of pluto nash those flops
didn't exactly help his career but
thanks to coming to america too and
2019's dolomite is my name the actor has
once again entered the limelight what a
totally unexpected surprise
it's almost hard to believe the number
of recognizable roles the actor has to
his name but one more could have been
added to that list what movie does
murphy still regret turning down after
all these years you might be surprised
to learn that it was none other than the
groundbreaking who framed roger rabbit
released in 1988 who framed roger rabbit
is a bold film that seamlessly blends
live action and animation into an
engaging story that still holds up
against modern standards the movie stars
bob hoskins as eddie valiant a private
detective who gets drawn into a murder
investigation involving roger rabbit the
movie was an unmitigated success it
currently holds a 97 on rotten tomatoes
and earned over 154 million dollars
domestically against a 70 million dollar
budget but tell me eddie is that a
rabbit in your pocket you're just happy
to see me
while speaking with jimmy fallon in late
2019 eddie murphy said that he was
offered the starring role of eddie
valiant he passed on the film because
the concept was so unusual that he
didn't think it had any chance of being
a success and i was like
what animation in people that sound like
[ __ ] to me
now every time i see it like
with murphy in the lead role who framed
roger rabbit would have undoubtedly been
a very different movie than the one we
know now but that's just the way the
business goes hollywood is filled with
countless what-if stories actors turn
down roles or back out for various
reasons and as it turns out murphy more
than has his fair share of these stories
in addition to missing out on who framed
roger rabbit murphy most notably lost
the chance to star in 1984's
ghostbusters murphy could have played
winston but he instead opted to star in
beverly hills cop it proved to be a
fruitful move rather than feature as one
person in an ensemble murphy had the
chance to lead a film that went on to
spawn two sequels but that wasn't
necessarily a strategic decision on
murphy's part the actor claimed in an
interview with extra in 2003 that like
roger rabbit he also turned down
ghostbusters because he didn't see the
premise having any chance of success as
he put it at the time quote this sounds
like a crock the actor also passed on
starring as detective carter in the hit
action comedy rush hour to instead star
in the widely forgotten holy man
i guess that's a good way to go
rush hour would spawn several sequels
while holy man was a box office and
critical bomb in an interview with extra
murphy dished on the process with his
usual sense of humor saying it's funny
when i think of it now it was like you
can go jump all over california with
jackie chan or go to miami and wear a
robe for three months i went to miami
and you see the results funnily enough
even though murphy turned down rush hour
he actually inspired the entire film
according to an interview the eventual
rush hour star chris tucker gave to east
coast radio when uh eddie murphy did
beverly hills cop yeah that's that's my
rush hour i wanted to that's why rush
hour came about because because of eddie
murphy's beverly hills cop
but despite missing out on all these
blockbuster movies murphy has still only
claimed to regret turning down who
framed roger rabbit fortunately thanks
to his recent resurgence murphy isn't
hurting for good roles these days all
these years later it's safe to say he's
still got it
yeah you still got it
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]